نحن نغير شكل المستقبل
مع Galaxy Z Flip عندما يكون مغلقًا ،
إنه شيء جميل إنه سلس
وأنيق ومتناسق وبنصف
حجمه الكامل يناسب راحة يدي
ومريح في جيبي
وشاشة الغطاء  يُظهر لي كل المعلومات التي
قد أحتاجها ، إنها لمحة عندما أكون جاهزًا
لاستخدامها ، كل ما علي فعله هو قلبها
لفتحها وأحصل على شاشة بحجم 6.7 بوصة
بالكاد مع أي إطار
وقد تعتقد أن زجاجًا قابل للطي
سيكون هشًا ولكن هذا الزجاج مصمم
ليدوم طويلاً ويحمي شاشتك من
الخدوش إنه متين للغاية بحيث يمكنك
طي هاتفك وفتحه أكثر من 200000 مرة
قمنا ببناء مفصل توقف مجاني حتى
يظل مفتوحًا من زوايا مختلفة تمامًا مثل
الكمبيوتر المحمول الذي نطلق عليه  الوضع المرن في الوضع المرن ،
ستحصل على نوع جديد من تجربة الهاتف الذكي ، حيث
يتم تقسيم شاشتك إلى
جزأين منطقة عرض ومنطقة تفاعل
وقمنا بتحسين بعض
تطبيقاتك المفضلة لهذا الغرض أو سيتم
ضبطها تلقائيًا على سبيل المثال إذا
كنت  مشاهدة يو  uTube وتريد
ترك تعليق يمكنك مشاهدته في النصف العلوي
من شاشتك والتعليقات في
الجزء السفلي ، يمكنك حتى دعم
هاتفك بمفرده والدردشة المرئية أو التقاط
صورة سيلفي بدون استخدام اليدين ، تأتي galaxy Z flip
بثلاثة صور رائعة  تعكس الألوان
مرآة أرجوانية سوداء وفي
بلدان محددة ، تتغير هذه الألوان الأنيقة في بلدان محددة
عندما يضربها الضوء ،
وستظل دائمًا تلفت الانتباه
وتحول الرؤوس ، وعندما تغلق تتيح
لك قطع الاتصال دون أن تفوتك ،
يمكنك التحقق من الوقت الذي تحصل فيه على
إشعارات  إنذار نصي أو مكالمة ، كل
الأساسيات موجودة على شاشة الغلاف ،
يمكنك حتى التقاط صورة سيلفي
دون فتح الهاتف ، فقط
أمسك الكاميرا الخلفية
واستخدم شاشة الغطاء كمحدد للمشهد ،
يمكن أن تكون لك من 14 سنة وهي
متوفر ابتداءً من ألف
وثلاثمائة وثمانين دولاراً